hey crazies this mirror reflects all
visible light but so does this piece of
paper what's the difference
why aren't they the same I actually get
this question a lot in the comments
let's see where it takes us
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon alright
so the quick answer is that there's two
different kinds of reflection the mirror
sends the light in a very specific
direction we call this specular
reflection because specular means mirror
in Latin with this kind of reflection
you see a different image depending on
how you look in the mirror the image
changes as you move around a room it
gives you the illusion you're looking
through a window into some mirror
universe paper is a little different
with paper the light scatters instead it
spreads out so we call it diffuse
reflection if you move around the room
you'll keep seeing the same thing white
the word reflection is pretty fitting
for both types though it comes from the
Latin reflector a meaning to bend
backward which is exactly what both
types of reflection do they bend the
light backward but in very different
ways they're gonna end up being the same
aren't they yep you're finally learning
okay so you're probably wondering how
that's possible how could these two
different phenomena be the same well the
usual explanation goes something like
this a mirror is incredibly smooth even
under a microscope so the surface always
faces the same direction but with
something like paper the surface has
tiny imperfections the light still obeys
the law of reflection and each separate
spot but different spots face different
directions so the light scatters instead
it sounds pretty convincing except it
can't be the whole story if it were a
rough piece of silver would look white
and it doesn't but it's definitely part
of the explanation I mean all of us can
tell this smooth piece of plastic is not
a mirror but it definitely has some
mirror-like effects
it's just not the whole explanation
there must be something else going on
here hmm we're gonna have to go deeper
like literally deeper into the material
so so the mirrored surface is made of
atoms usually silver some other shiny
metal we like to imagine that light
interacts with the atoms on top but
there are spaces between those atoms
that the light can fit through
scattering can happen off many layers of
atoms and still contribute to the
reflected light the mirror like
reflection in this plastic is from the
surface atoms the color is from the
layers underneath and that's not even
considering the wave nature of light if
we do that each of those atoms sends out
its own light in all directions
including into the material ultimately
those light waves cancel except in two
specific directions you heard me right
the incoming beam splits in two at any
surface it doesn't have to be
transparent some of the light will
reflect we call that the reflected light
for obvious reasons the rest will move
forward into the new material we call
that the transmitted or refracted light
how much is reflected and transmitted
depends on lots of things the materials
involve the incoming angle the frequency
of the light etc for an air glass
boundary the light is about five percent
reflective and 95 percent transmitted
because transparency for a mirrored
surface it's the other way around the
point is there's always some transmitted
light even for a mirror what makes
materials different is how far that
transmitted light can go it's something
we call penetration depth
the penetration depth depends on four
things the electric and magnetic field
properties of the material the frequency
of the incoming light and most
importantly the electrical resistance
the material can provide the three
material properties are just numbers you
look up in a table like this one from
engineering toolbox as always links in
the doobly-doo I've calculated a couple
of these depths just so you can get some
perspective the penetration depth for
glass is 156 point five meters it's over
500 feet for a silver mirror it's 1.4
nanometers that's drastically different
from glass so it goes in that bar and
just stops well no the light intensity
drops off exponentially a penetration
depth of 1.4 nanometers means that for
every 1.4 nanometers the light goes into
the silver the intensity goes down by a
factor of e at one penetration depth the
intensity is 37% of the original at five
penetration depths the intensity drops
below 1% for the silver mirror that's
still only seven nanometers that
transmitted light is going nowhere fast
based on this equation we can see
transmitted light won't go as far in
electrical conductors that's what gives
metals that distinctive metal coloring
we all recognize the light barely
penetrates so why aren't all insulators
transparent oh whoops
there's one more issue we have to
resolve these atoms need energy to send
out their own light it doesn't come out
of nowhere energy must be conserved
conservation of energy shall not be by
legend that incoming light is absorbed
and used what there's a catch there are
two different ways that light can be
absorbed by those atoms resonant
absorption and dissipative absorption I
know I know those are some serious $10
words but they're not as fancy as they
sound resonant absorption is when a
single electron absorbs a single photon
with just the right energy needed to
bump the electron to a higher energy
level
this is the kind of absorption their
results in things like fluorescence and
phosphorescence this is not the kind of
absorption that creates reflected and
transmitted light beams
I repeat resonant absorption does not
create reflected and transmitted light
beams when this happens the electron
usually doesn't have a chance to remit
that light it gets stolen by neighboring
atoms as heat instead this is the light
that heats up a material fluorescence
and phosphorescence are just special
exceptions reflected and transmitted
beams come from the other type of
absorption dissipative absorption this
type does not require quantum mechanics
it is a very classical effect an atom is
just minding its own business when some
light comes along because the atom is
made of charge the lights electric field
drives the atoms motion the atom
vibrates at the same frequency as the
light vibration is a kind of
acceleration and accelerated charges
emit light this vibration causes the
atom to send out its own light which
combines with the light from other atoms
how all that light combines depends on
lots of things like atomic spacing
response lags vibrational damping and
resonances
it's too many things for our brains to
handle so we take that overwhelming
amount of information and summarize it
as a single unit list number the
refractive index that's another number
you just look up in a table somewhere if
we have that number we can forget atoms
and molecules even exist
all we need to know is the type of
material and we're good to go
just keep in mind this refractive index
depends slightly on the frequency of the
incoming light different kinds of light
can reflect or transmit better than
others that's what gives everything
their color even off of a mirror green
reflects better than other colors which
is why if you look deep into mirror
infinity things tend to start turning
green so why isn't everything a mirror
well a few reasons first the surface has
to be really smooth too many
imperfections and the light will scatter
second the surface has to be a good
electrical
that way the light barely penetrates
silver is the best but it's also
expensive so a lot of mirrors are made
of aluminum instead
lastly the light shining on the surface
can't match the quantum energy gaps of
the electrons otherwise the light is
destined to become heat rather than a
reflection if you check all those boxes
you've got yourself a mirror if not
it'll just be a solid color so got any
more questions about mirrors please ask
in the comments thanks for liking and
sharing this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy several of you
asked if anyone had ever done
diffraction off of a mirror oh yeah
for sure I actually had to do it as a
lab in modern physics and undergrad it's
totally a thing a nice reflective metal
ruler is basically a diffraction grating
feel free to try it at home if you've
got one anyway thanks for watching